c'était en 2013 peu après avoir remporté
un prix de jeunes entrepreneurs
stéphane et angie font une vidéo de
promo à la demande de la région cinq ans
plus tard stéphane vient de faire une
deuxième vidéo mais le temps n'est pas
le même
le jeune homme doit fermer l'entreprise
et c'est un véritable parcours du
combattant
j'ai déjà pays 283 euros à la chambre
des métiers pour faire partir la
procédure de la comédie ça va vous
prendre 15 jours à 1 mois pour que la
dissolution la modification soit
effective et ge après un mois je vais au
tribunal peut chercher mon document qui
était censé arriver par la poste pour
que me disent que rien n'a été fait donc
j'ai payé 4 283 euros à la chambre des
métiers pour que rien ne soit fait le
problème c'est qu'avec un statut
d'entrepreneur ils n'ont pas droit aux
formations ni au rsa à basse-pointe 100
véhicules sont revenus ils essaient en
vain de récupérer les documents
pourquoi j'ai fait une vidéo vous allez
voir avec moi j'ai commencé à 8h30 10h30
chez plus je connais le numéro du
tribunal de grande instance parker
maintenant 48 41 2 fois et quand tu
appelles ya personne qui répond il faut
manger bois faut s'habiller faut vivre
et c'est de pas pété les plombs quand
même
mais plus patiente et par deux fois la
fête
kenny belaey gherbi patienter encore
quelques cas nous retrouvons les deux
jeunes à basse pointe de leur entreprise
informatique faute de clients il ne
reste plus que des souvenirs des dettes
et un goût amer on a essayé de créer une
entreprise essaie de faire les choses
bougent et contre l entreprise
six ponts mais ce n'est pas aussi que
pour nom parce qu' on essaie aussi de
développer un peu la ville essayer de
faire les choses bougent et qu'en tant
que jeunes entrepreneurs ils ont vu
qu'on voit le résultat
[Musique]
la vidéo s'est répandue comme une
traînée de poudre nombreux sont ceux qui
se reconnaissent dans ce dialogue de
sourds avec l'administration
la démonstration de stéphane dure 18
minutes jamais le tribunal ne décroche
bah oui j'allais pas visionnage un petit
mais pas besoin d'argent ces montants là
bas but alors qu'ils femmes au café donc
un métier comme un caban noir dans les
blocs là à l'heure où nous parlons
stéphane a réussi à récupérer l'un des
documents mais seule la mairie de basse
pointe et des associations ont pris
contact avec lui